this is Sarah the registered nurse RN
calm and in this video I'm going to be
going over at the vaccination schedule
for children zero to six years and I'm
going to be giving you some mnemonics on
how you can remember all these vaccines
and as always at the end of this YouTube
video you can access the free quiz that
will test you on this material so let's
get started we will start with birth and
this is super easy all that's required
at birth is the hepatitis B vaccine and
there will be three doses given in the
first dose will be I birth next is it
two months and they will get several
vaccines at this visit they will get the
hepatitis B which will be your second
dose our DTaP which is for diphtheria
tetanus and pertussis the hip vaccine
which is for Hamas Phyllis influenza
type B which will help prevent against
epiglottitis polio the pneumococcal
conjugate vaccine which is the PCV and
then the RV vaccine which is the
rotavirus vaccine then at four months
they will get everything they got at two
months except the hepatitis B vaccine so
they will get the D type they will get
the hip polio PCV and RV then it's six
months it's really easy because it's
exactly what they got at two months
which will include hepatitis B the D
type the hip polio PCV and the RV and
then also at six months they will start
receiving an annual flu vaccine so if
you can remember from 2 to 6 months they
get exactly the same vaccines and it's
six of them but then at four months they
will get everything except hepatitis B
then we move on to 12 to 18 months so
here the child will get the D top and
they'll get this at the 15 to 18 month
mark and then hip PCV the MMR which is
new we're adding on and the varicella
which is chicken pox and then they'll
also get the hepatitis A vaccine which
is going to be required
in two doses they'll get one dose at 12
months which is one year and then
they'll get the second dose six months
later at eighteen months and of course
the annual flu shot during flu season
and finally between four to six years
old they will get the falling vaccines
and there's only four of them so I think
that's easy because I remember that it
starts at four years so they'll get the
DTaP polio MMR and the varicella and of
course if it's flu season they'll get
the annual flu shot now let's go over
some new monix to help you remember when
these vaccines should be given okay at
birth that is easy they just need one
vaccine and it's the hepatitis B vaccine
so birth hepatitis B you can remember
that one just one now let's remember the
vaccines from two to six months because
if we can remember all these vaccines we
just have to remember those and we've
knocked out a lot of them so whenever I
created these mnemonics I wanted them to
be able to help you to identify what age
they need to be given what exactly is
given so as I pointed out earlier at two
months and six months it's the same
exact vaccines that are being given
there's six of them but it's changed it
for months all of those are being given
except hepatitis B so this mnemonic is
going to help you remember that it says
two six month old pediatric policies
discuss rejecting his Hep B at four
months so this tells us that at two and
six months the child will need the
following pediatric represents
pneumococcal conjugate virus the PCV
policies represents polio disgust
represents DTaP rejecting represents
rotavirus his represents him and Hep B
represents of course hepatitis B and it
ends at four months so it's telling us
that the child will need all those
vaccines except hence rejecting the Hep
B at four months now let's look at some
mnemonics for the next to a
categories okay we're doing 12 to 18
months and remember with this one we're
going to be giving D top hip PCB but
we're adding on MMR and varicella and
Hep A and remember Hep A is going to be
given in two doses one at 12 months and
then one six months later at 18 months
so here's a mnemonic to help you
remember all those in that category his
12 to 18 dispatch montt vaccines helped
people his represents him told the 18
represents the category we're talking
about of Ages so 12 to 18
dispatch represents DTaP mump represents
MMR vaccines represents the varicella
helped represents Hep A remember there's
two doses of that one given at this age
group and then people represents PCV and
lastly to help us remember four to six
years remember there's just four of them
you can remember this mnemonic police
dispatch four to six year old month
vaccines so police represents polio this
Factory represents DTaP 46 year old is
the age category month is the measles
mumps rubella vaccine and then vaccine
represents varicella okay so those are
the recommended vaccines for children
ages 0 to 6 thank you so much for
watching don't forget to take the free
quiz and to subscribe to our channel for
more videos